ethereal and fleeting mesmerizing and
elusive
these floating blue flames have been a
mainstay in european folklore since
at least the 14th century you may have
heard of the name willow the wisp but do
you know what it
is stories of sentient blue flames
floating and bouncing across marshes and
bogs
permeate cultures from northern europe
to australia
while some stories have faded into
ephemera just as the floating blue
flames that inspired them
these elusive creatures remain mainstays
of myth and legend in
pockets across the globe so
what are they fairies fireballs ghosts
atmospheric phenomena here's the
haunting history
of the willow the wisp i'm dr emily
zarka
and this is monstrum the will of the
wisp are most frequently described as
small
moving blue flames that hover a few feet
off the ground
and do not flicker cold or cool to the
touch
if you're brave or reckless enough to
touch one they can be found in
marshland's bogs and swamps
all treacherous places to wander even
without the alluring glow of the will of
the wisp leading you deeper into danger
follow the will of the wisp seductive
dance and you may find hidden treasure
or watery grave stories of these elusive
and inscrutable flames
vary some say spotting the floating
flame is an
indication that someone is blessed with
the power of foresight
but more often folklore and literature
paints them as impish tricksters
restless spirits or malevolent beings in
sweden willow the wisps are ghosts with
lanterns fated to wander aimlessly for
removing their neighbor's boundary
markers
in english tradition the blue flames are
lights carried by elves
and in australia the light may approach
someone but
anyone who tries to catch it will
disappear other tales say the lights are
crafted by
fairies or even a fire species all its
own
in belgium and the netherlands they are
the lost spirits of unbaptized children
while in other places the floating
flames are said to be the wandering
souls
of unhappy women unrighteous men priests
who have broken their vow of chastity
or even those souls who escaped
purgatory
in fact the ethereal light gleans its
most enduring name
willow the wisp or will with a wisp from
the saxon
word while for fraud trick or deceit and
the swedish word wisp
meaning a small lit bundle of tinder
variations include will with the wisp
willy wisp and will owe the wikes
essentially the name hints that the
light comes from some trickster spirit
holding a flame aloft
further north in norwegian folklore the
will of the wisp is called
haberdee's lantern hobbenese lantern or
even
hob and his lantern hob may come from
the norwegian
hopa meaning mare or the old norse word
hapa
which translates to leap or hop which
might not be as obvious a name as a
deceitful bundle of tinder
until you know that the will of the wisp
movement often resembles the cantering
motion of a horse yet another moniker
for the floating lights
jackie lantern or jack-o-lantern yes
that's right the carved pumpkins that
adorn many a stoop or doorstep on
halloween
actually borrow their name from this
mysterious light
jack-o'-lantern is of english language
origin and simply means
jack of the lantern so when did we start
hearing about these creatures
well the first recorded sighting of will
of the wisp is described in a 1340 text
pen by welsh poet david apgulem he wrote
that in every hollow live a hundred
rye-mouthed wisps
he names the phenomenon canulkorf welsh
for corpse candle
thereby introducing what will become
another common name for the supernatural
blue flames
and associating the lights with death
and burial sites
the first appearance of the lights in
the english language occurs in 1563
under the name ignis fatuous here they
are described as foolish fire that
hurteth not
in another variation of the will of the
wisp myth the ghost lights are
attributed to a mischievous sprite
called a puck
which uses the light to lure humans to
fall into ditches bogs and pools
and then laughs at their predicament
before fleeing sometimes referred to in
this form as
walking fire it can also appear as a
horse bull or
eagle but it is always a trickster
shakespeare adopts the name puck for the
character of a shape-shifting sprite in
a midsummer night's stream
first performed around 1596 this puck
turns into a phosphorescent glow
and hovers over the marshes at night to
trick travelers
in henry iv he uses the name ignis
fatuous
to refer to a ball of wildfire the will
of the wisp
even appears in john milton's famous
epic poem paradise lost
as a malevolent distraction a wandering
fire compact of unctuous vapor
which the night condenses and the cold
environs round
kindled through agitation to a flame
which oft they say some evil spirit
attends
hovering and blazing with delusive light
misleads the amazed night wanderer from
his way
to bogs and mires and oft through pond
or pool
like many other references in literature
and folklore milton's will of the wisp
is associated with danger
bad news and even death but over time
the elusive blue flame
also became a literary metaphor for
anything that is just out of reach
a delusion one may chase endlessly but
unsuccessfully
willow the wisp sightings are reported
across the globe
and the frequency of their marshland
appearances points to a very
real origin the stories may be made up
but the lights themselves are
not there's scientific truth to these
reports
theories explaining the will of the wisp
phenomenon circulated in scientific
communities for
hundreds of years in fact in 1704
isaac newton wrote in optics of the
ignis fatuous as vapors shining without
heat
the vague statement unsurprisingly
sparked vigorous debate in the academic
communities of the 18th and 19th
centuries
english folklorist and historian jabez
elise traveled over europe collecting
stories and evidence of
antiquity and in 1839 he got lucky with
his own first-hand experience catching a
glimpse of the mysterious flame
elise claims that while traveling near
worcestershire in england
he saw the will of the wisp he described
the light as very clear and strong
unwavering and much bluer in color than
a candle
he wrote sometimes it was only like a
flash in the pan on the ground
at other times it rose up several feet
and fell to the earth
and became extinguished and many times
it proceeded horizontally from 50 to 100
yards
with an undulating motion like the
flight of the green woodpecker and about
as rapid
and once or twice it proceeded with
considerable rapidity in a straight line
upon or close to the ground elise
reports that the two nights in a row he
saw the phenomenon
there were only minimal clouds and
bright starlight
both evenings were rather warm and had
no fog
he speculates that the wild wisps appear
on nights after a rainfall in the winter
season
was elise onto something what else could
explain these odd flames
fireflies too small and they glow with a
yellow or green flickering light
glow worms the females do produce a
bright light but don't fly
male glow worms fly but don't glow st
elmo's fire perhaps the plasma creating
weather phenomenon does produce a blue
glow
though it requires a strong electrical
field in the atmosphere
and an encounter with a conductor like
the mast of a ship or the wing of a
plane
which doesn't appear in reported will
the wisp sightings
what about ball lightning spherical
glowing and capable of lasting for
longer than a brief flash
yes but only during thunderstorms with
ranges in color and usually accompanied
by a hissing sound
and a distinct odor will the wisp aren't
associated with
any smell and only seem to appear a day
or more
after rainfall or storm perhaps then
dare i say it luminous owls an unusual
occurrence in which the feathers of the
bird are contaminated by a fungus
whose metabolic process produces a glow
when the owl is in the dark
but will of the wisps move more slowly
than owls typically hunt and don't tend
to cover much ground
the most likely explanation spontaneous
combustion of marsh or swamp gas
a rationale proposed at least as early
as 1729 by w
durham who after observing the
phenomenon over half a decade
directly refuted the hypothesis that the
lights were caused by glowworms flying
together
given the frequently reported occurrence
of the will of the wisp on marshlands
swamps and bogs
swamp gas seems pretty plausible made up
of about 60
methane as well as other components like
carbon dioxide
swamp gas is the byproduct of
decomposing vegetation
in areas like swamps marshes and even
landfills
and in some rare cases if there is
enough heat and oxygen produced by the
metabolic process
the gas can spontaneously combust and
produce
fire and methane just happens to burn
with a blue flame and a yellowish glow
will the mystery of the will of the wisp
ever truly be solved
even today many people swear the will of
the wisp is a supernatural or paranormal
experience
interestingly there have been no modern
encounters with the will of the wisp
and therefore no new data to add to any
potential debunking theories
perhaps there are no more will the wisk
because we have drained and demolished
so many marshes and lowlands maybe we'll
never know what caused the glowing blue
flames spotted so many years ago
and i kind of like that glow on
mysterious fiery orbs
glow on oh god it's gonna happen
sorry david
i'm so sorry